Now we've seen how to control the way computers make decisions by
giving them information from the outside world about data that can change,
like traffic lights, weather or pass
codes and we can create programs that react to this data.
We use booleans to test whether data falls into conditions that are either true or
false and then use control flow to create
decision pathways to take with if and else statements.
And decisions are important for so many applications.
We've seen how it applies to self-driving cars and
automated behavior like setting museum admission prices.
After learning about control flow you're well on
your way to making smart and efficient programs.
Next we'll learn how to effectively group code
together with functions. Let's keep learning.